this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 18th of july the joint is
brought to you by freeze pipe
listen no matter how [__] hot it gets
outside and it's [__] hot you keep
your bun nice and nice cold you freeze
it you pack it up and then you [__]
rip it when you hit the hot smoke pass
it through the [__] frozen part
cooling down the smoke as you inhale
your smoke is so cold they'll be [__]
calling you chili [__] willy i love
the joint freeze pipe i love the [__]
bong
i love the bubbler i mean they [__] if
you want to see the devil in a clean
nice way and feel good about it
the freeze pipe is for you
freeze pipe is non-toxic and it freezes
faster than water and it stays frozen
longer freeze pipe cools down the smoke
by hundreds of degrees your throat won't
burn
your lungs won't burn you'll feel a lot
better what the [__] uncle joey's taking
care of you [__] so do me a favor
go to the
freezepipe.com thefreezepipe.com
press and code joey to save 10
off your first order get yourself a new
bong a pipe or a bubbler all of them are
gonna make one of your [__] eyeballs
pop out of your head and even when the
freeze pipe pops that eyeball out you'll
go
this is the [__] best so that's the
t-h-e freeze pipe dot com
pressing code joey j-o-e-y
to save ten percent
freeze pipe it's like a [__] snowball
and a ball you're gonna love it the
joint is also brought to you by cbd lion
listen man my [__] elbows were
hurting from i don't know what the [__]
i was trying to do pull-ups you know i
haven't done a pull-up in years
and i put some [__] cbd lion cream on
it the next day
i was [__] throwing darts like i was
chinese i'm a bad [__] but it's
not even me it's cbd lion go to
cbdline.com right now
read the third party lab results why are
you buying your cbd from these [__]
jokers i've been smoking dope since they
invented it the blue bird from china
came to me and told me to smoke that
[__] cbd lion is the way to go
they also have delta eight
gummies that'll push another planet if
you go to cbd line you read the third
party lab results
you're going to get 20 off if you put in
code joey joint or church
take a shot columbus did you have pains
the tincture is [__] amazing if
you're not using cbd
tincture at night before you go to bed
to relax you
you're [__] slipping go to
cbdlion.com
read the third-party lab results and you
[__] tell me what you think cbd line
is the best
pressing code joey a joint to get 20 off
now without further ado let's get to
some [__] talking it's 1993 in this
[__] today
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint the 18th
and the 20th the [__] july jesus
christ
this [__] is moving right the [__] along
man
it's crazy if it's the 20th today
tomorrow
it's 40 years
that i [__] uh banged this girl that
told me i would never bang her it took
me three years to get in her pants but i
[__] did it
we're still friends we talked from time
to time she's a friend of mine on
facebook but i i love all that [__] when
somebody tells you you can't [__] do
like she's like it's never gonna happen
don't even ask me out she told me that
like sophomore year i'm like i'm gonna
make a mental [__] note about that
and i worked on like a [__] you know
brought a chocolate walk to home i did
all that [__] [__] you do what you got
to do you understand me if you don't
like porn you got to do what you do to
[__] get that monkey from time to
time three years to get that [__]
monkey that's persistence you understand
me and at the time i wasn't even
intersex like i was too young i was
doing coke and [__]
you know but
don't ever tell me it's not gonna
[__] happen
anyway it's crazy because that's the
worst thing for people when you tell
somebody they're not gonna do it like
that's my last resort with people if
somebody's having a problem or something
and they're like listen to the you know
just [__] uh either do it or [__]
don't is you have to have that little
chit chat with them from time to time
and it sucks but anyway i was thinking
about 1990 [__] three you know i'm
looking through this book now we're
going through chapters just uh
to see what the [__] is going on if
everything fits and [__] every morning
we're gonna have like a little
conference call to go over the chapters
the next month is legal
so august i start the legal uh portion
of the book
where we hop on the phone with [__]
lawyers and [__] and they tell us what i
can't and can put in the [__] book
and uh it's crazy because i put some
stories in there guys i told you that i
told you guys
early on that i had
i have a thousand stories
you know i got a thousand stories if i
sit and think
and somebody brings something up i could
think of a [__] story you know i'll
make a few calls to verify it but i have
a thousand stories but i also have ten
thousand stories that i can't say
i can't say because it'll implicate
somebody else i can't say because
maybe i was scared to
you know tell people the facts you know
about what happened at that time
i was always scared to tell anybody
of what would really happen in 1993 when
i came back here i've always been uh
and since you guys are podcast followers
and stuff and you've been around for a
while i'm gonna tell you a couple of
these [__] things because i'm not
really proud of this
but the moral of this story is i can't
believe
that i was doing comedy
and making hedgeway
while i was doing these [__]
living this [__] crazy life
i mean my nine months that i spent in
new jersey in 93 after i got divorced
really [__] uh it it brought me home
like i hadn't been home since like 85 it
it leveled me it brought me back my mind
of being a north bergen guy you know how
we work how we operate
but it also got everything
like when i came back in 93 i hooked up
with some old friends
and
if you think i was crazy at that [__]
time these guys had been
like the [__] i stopped and i went to
prison these guys kept going and they
let normal lies but once a week they did
a hit
or they did like [__] they robbed the
truck or they helped somebody unlock
they always did something
on the up and up i had a handful of
these guys but there was one guy in
particular
that i knew since the eighth grade he
took to me when i got older
uh
we were both [__] junkies you know i
loved him with all my heart he [__]
loved me
and in 93 we had had ups and downs over
the year but 93 when i came back he was
getting married
and i told him i was doing comedy we had
reconnected after i don't know six years
not speaking
and he's like you're really going to do
comedy and you know like when everybody
in the world tells you you're crazy for
picking something like
this guy was the craziest guy i knew
like he was out there as a human being
as a criminal he was a [__]
sweetheart in real life but he'd eat
your [__] lunch and he and he'd take
your [__] lunch
you know yesterday i was at at the park
watching one of my
uh jimmy florentine's son was playing
basketball so i went down at 5 30 uh
monday night and then we were gonna go
to osteria for hamburger for
cheeseburger night
so i went down there and there was these
dudes on the court about like 18 they
were like 18 year old seniors you know
and all if there were six of them four
of them were steroided at
and then the coach said listen it's
really hot on this
court can we play on this court and the
six dudes were like yeah whatever you
know
they were agreeing to it but they were
kind of being dickish about it like how
old are these kids like during the fifth
grade cool like you know they were
trying to be nice
and i watched them i was watching the
game i'm sitting next to my wife i'm
talking to [__] parents
and i'm watching these five kids and i
go wow
if i was 18 and i came down here when i
was 18 with like mike ronnie my brother
and this guy darren rego
they would
[__] roll those guys
like i'm telling you
they would beat them up and take their
[__] and then send them home the six
kids could have surrounded those two
monsters
they would have cleaned their [__]
clock taking them and i told my wife my
wife's like those kids are [__]
annoying and i'm like you know what's
crazy i wish you would have seen my
brother mike and dan rhaegar
they would have came down here
they would have taken those kids apart
it's a different world i know those kids
are popular they're good-looking and
[__] and they're all steroided out but i
can tell you they got no [__] heart
my friends would come down here beat
them to death
and take their [__] and sure enough and
i go you know why they have no heart
because they're spoiled
they're spoiled kids they don't know
anything about you could see them
giggling like [__] [__]
with no shirts on six of them and i'm
like my friends would have [__] taken
everything from and my wife tapped me on
the shoulders they were leaving she goes
you're right look at that that's an
eighty thousand dollar truck how do i
know cause my brother's got one these
kids were in high school driving a eight
thousand dollar truck and i'll tell you
something else my brother mike ronnie
would have taken that too
that and and i wish
i wish i was [__] lying to you guys
you know
when i went back to north bergen i had
some sweetheart friends i had some
friends that made me laugh
i had friends that [__] uh you know
helped me get high nobody ever had to
help me get high but you know what i'm
saying like we'd mix forces to get high
and then they go their way
and i go my way and by the time 1993
came i didn't i had lost contact
with like darren mike ronnie i always
speak to once a week twice a week
but uh i lost contact with diamonds when
he came up to when i told him i was
doing comedy and what my i was getting
the boy
i got divorced i had no money i'm broke
i got nothing you know i could be that
honest with this kid and he's like dog
if you're doing comedy you put your
heart into it
i'll do whatever you need i'll write you
i'll give you money and i was like
wow
out of all the [__] people i think
would support me
this guy and i got to be honest
i'm exaggerating a little bit because in
93 when i came back i did the show at
romano's
and my [__] friends came and i just
showed up there i didn't have a show
there was a show at the bar called
romano's
and my friends uh said let's go up there
and see what it's about maybe they'll
put you on stage and i went down and i
met gonzo good guy bob gonzo
this is 1993 gonzo's still doing comedy
rooms in new jersey i see him on
facebook all the time
i walk the [__] gonzo i'm a comic i'm
doing comedy like two years i want to
know i don't even want to go out
i just want to let you know i'm
available and if i could ever come and
do a free set you know that's what you
do when you're a comic and this is my
right in my hometown a little town
called guttenberg within north bergen
what [__] thank you for introducing
yourself liquid iv it's a hot [__]
day thank you for introducing yourself
uh
yeah give me your number and i'll call
you that was about like in the beginning
of the show
midway in the show he came up to me he
was dog
i'm gonna have to put you on stage
because your friends threatened me
i go what he goes that little guy over
there he [__] threatened me he's
talking about damn right
he goes he told me to put you up on
stage i don't want no problem with these
guys i'll put you up and i went up on
stage and my friends went [__] ape
[__] they were clapping yelling and [__]
drinking snorting blow it was [__]
nuts
and that night a couple of them were
like coco we're [__] happy you're
doing this man
keep doing it i sucked i sucked i just
talked about my friends i talked about
north bergen about my friends but i
that night i got some support and then
darren was like i'm all over it call me
when you want to do spots in the city
blah blah blah
at that time there was like bananas
rascals north rascal south i wasn't good
enough to play any of these clubs the
stress factory
i was still like an open mic trying to
find my way around i got a job driving
limos and i
over time i just put a schedule together
and i would go out at night and do
stand-up spots in new york i i sucked
that's how i met michael buchetti that's
how i would go to the old triple-n it
was a rough [__] time guys i could
sit here and lie to you it was rough
when you're doing open mics it's [__]
rough and i'm working and i'm going
through a war with my ex-wife and i'm
fighting with my wife over the kid and
but i'm a [__] open miker now let's
just take that i'm an open mic most open
mic is a young guys they have a day job
maybe they got a girlfriend maybe
they're married they got no [__]
drama at the open mics every once in a
while a guy comes in he got beat up by
his wife you know in seattle that open
mic every week somebody came in with
something comic came in one night
holding his stomach his wife stabbed him
no
comedy open mics you don't know what the
[__] i expect you know
i was getting tortured at these [__]
places like
and you got to keep your mouth shut
you know people have when you're on the
bottom of the [__] when people are
[__] on you you got to keep your
mouth shut you know i had a couple
situations where i say things to people
one guy stole my joke i had to [__]
push him
you know [__] like that stupid stuff but
that was
looking back at that time when i was
reading this chapter last night or what
my day was like guys i would have to
take the 7 a.m bus so i wouldn't have to
pay to get into the city like i had my
friend's father drove a bus and he told
me if you get on the bus that in fact it
was darren's father he goes if you get
on my bus i'll never charge you just sit
next to me so i would make sure i get
that that's i was saving three dollars
when you're [__] saving three dollars
you're [__] broke like you're [__]
broke that three dollars was for a
muffin and a [__] orange juice and
port authority and then i would go to
work and then i would [__] change and
it was none
stop grinding
but
i was making a little bit of money
and then i told some of my friends i
needed to make some money and they
gave me different scams i had my buddy
lubes hit me with a [__] id scam
and i was picking up two or three
thousand dollars here and there i was
delivering sandwiches i was selling cars
i was driving a limo
i was [__] oh you know what they call
that [__] when you're over max at the
checking account whether they say you're
over overextended on your cr i was
overextended in my [__] life
but that's what it means to be an open
micr and that's what it means to be
young you have all this time no
responsibility you got to fill up your
[__] schedule there's no time to
watch tv and sit around you're [__]
free you have nothing you know
and it was so weird because when i got
into comedy i was married and i had this
[__] regimen and i'm like how am i
going to do comedy and then one day the
god blessed me and he made my ex-wife
dump me and i was like cause i was a
[__] stiff
and i never forget that she dumped me
i'm going thank god now i could do
comedy
like it was the most bittersweet [__]
thing that ever happened to me like
i'm leaving you
but at the same time hey now you could
do comedy which is what you really
[__] wanted to do anyway so
but when i asked my friends if i wanted
to make money one friend approached me
he's like man i got a
way to make a ton of [__] money
in fact would remind me of all this was
two days ago it was one of these guys
birthdays that
my friend wanted me to rob he's he's out
of the drug business and [__] he's old
now my friend kept saying he had a
suitcase with 50 000 in it all we had to
do was break his window and grab the
suitcase and [__] but one of my other
friends beat me to it but the guy stole
the wrong suitcase with like two
thousand dollars in it so trust me
i'm from a [__] family of not good
criminals
but i didn't you know i just come out of
jail
i was at war with my ex-wife anything
like if i got arrested for [__]
anything it would have set me back 20
[__] years and it you know i was set
back anyway it wasn't a made a
difference but at that time i really
[__] walked on my p's and q's because
any police contact she was going to take
that to the courts and [__] rape me
with it so i was playing my p's and q's
that's why i was delivering sandwiches
the only thing i was doing illegal those
days was snorting coke and buying coke
that's it i was buying coke for me and
snorting coke that's okay she knew i got
high she didn't know the extent of it
but i wasn't doing anything then as i
got the
listen i'm a walking felony i do a
felony every day and i don't even know
i'm [__] doing it whether it's cut
off a mailman you're always doing
something that ain't [__] right all
right in my world i'm always doing
something that ain't right every day i
committed a felony when i was a [__]
kid
robbery or whatever
so i didn't want to get in trouble
so these guys kept asking me you know do
you want to do nah
and i tried going straight guys and it
worked for a few months it worked but
it's a lot of [__] work going
straight especially when you have no
education you're [__] a lot like i
was you know you're gonna always find a
job but while they're gonna pay you [__]
no
if i was making three thousand dollars a
month in those days
and that was paying child support
helping george's grandmother pay the
rent a little bit buy some groceries and
the rest went to
stupidity my cocaine use and whatever
the [__] else i was doing
so i was putting away a little money
i was paying child support i was sending
gifts home i was buying some clothes
from time to time
thank god cocaine was 35 a [__] grand
it was 35 a gram
it was 25 a gram 35 if you wanted it
uncut
are you kidding me
i was going over there every day for
[__] two grams like nothing so
finally like in july i'm like i gotta
figure something out you know i i don't
you know i didn't want to be a criminal
no more that's what i say to you guys
there's nobody better in any industry
that tried to clean himself up more than
me a thousand times when this book comes
out you're gonna be dizzy by how many
times i started over like i just
couldn't get it right i could not
get it right for the [__] life for me
and finally one day in july my friend
goes listen man
i got a friend
he uh gets badges and shirts from an
agency
he knows people and
you could help us flip some drug dealers
and i'm like god damn it
and what does this entail well we kick
down the door we neutralize everybody we
pull out our badges we [__]
tank up some of them you put ties on
some of them you might have to hit
somebody in the head with a gun to get
their attention
and then we rob he goes all the [__]
hits are pre-planned
everybody knows what's going down
you know we get our information
from these cops and we give them 25
of these [__] score and i'm like this
isn't [__] happening to me
this is not [__] happening to me i am
not getting approached for drug deals
but guys i had to do what i had to do
oh my god you guys you have no [__]
idea and so
i would meet these guys like once a week
and we would do creepy [__] things we
would
go to [__] harlem and follow drug
dealers and pull them over and you know
it was uh
the first i think i made like a i made
like nine grand
the first time i did something with them
and i paid my attorney off and i bought
some clothes i bought sneakers i bought
socks i mean that's how [__] poor i
was i don't want you to think i was
rocking and rolling and i would uh
resign to [__] do crimes i was not
rocking and rolling i was fighting for
every [__] dime i had i was it was 14
inches
every [__] day in my world and
that 9 000 caught me up with some child
support caught me up with the attorney
it gave me a little daylight so guys
once
you smell [__] blood i don't have to
tell you what happens once a shark days
blood he's going to keep doing it you
know and i
i quit my job delivering sandwiches
thank god
because it was in my hometown so all
these people that knew i was a loser now
had to see me in the deli making
sandwiches as a 32 year old [__] man
no i was 30 at the time 1993.
i got out of there because that didn't
make me feel right but i started making
little
people will put me on there on their
shows now i booked a private gig which i
bombed and i ate a bag of dog [__] but i
was making little strides with comedy
i'd signed myself up with that money for
a comedy class at the new york comedy
club the old one
so they came to me again they go do you
want to do another one and i was like
yeah
and uh
this one was rough we had to go into
people's houses and
tie them up and hold them down
i'm not proud of these things you know
because when i
when i got out of prison
i was like i love doing those drug rips
i [__] love them
you don't know what it is to make your
heart beat like that you know i watched
i once watched a show
about like people who did comedy and
musicians
that the reason why they get addicted
early on is because
you get a certain high when you go up on
stage you get a certain highway you
perform live you get a certain high when
you run you know there's run as high
there's all these highs and you want to
keep the party going
that's where the [__] addiction sets
in at that time i was totally gone guys
totally gone i did coke seven days a
week no reason to lie 35 [__] dollars
a gram or 25. you could always borrow 25
[__] dollars so i was it was a mess
and not in the daytime
never in the daytime always once i got
home at night and i [__] and that's
why i started because i was living with
george's grandmother so i i [__]
couldn't bring beer in the house you
know they would know that i was so
that's when i started snorting with no
alcohol and just getting high on cocaine
maybe do a [__]
line of heroin from time to time i mean
that's how crazy my life was in 1993.
so now
they come to me again this time we do
that [__] apartment in harlem
no guns went off
no nothing went off but
i didn't like the way the guys we tied
up were looking at me
like they just weren't
i didn't like that feeling when you tie
somebody up they look at you a weird
[__] way man
and uh you know you duct tape their feet
and [__] their legs it's
year's 30 years the statue limitations
it took me it took me [__] you know
it took me and i had mentioned these
stories from time to time not the extent
of them i mean you know
next time i do a thing with sickler i
break down some of those uh
drug rips that were just i mean guys you
go joey how the [__] did you get killed
i have no idea
i have no [__] idea
and that one
i got about 15 g's and about an ounce of
coke so that was pretty [__] good
[Music]
i paid more child support off
i paid the attorney off a little more
i gave some dough to grandma
there was somebody who i lent money that
lent me money that i had to pay them
back like a large amount oh mike
ronnie's wife
god rest her soul when i got into
stand-up she was one of a few people
that [__] supported me and she would
give me little envelopes on the side and
she would always go i don't want you to
be in the city without no money and i
would say i'm putting on a tab and i put
on the tab and i [__] paid it and uh
anyway
and then i was on my way i go i swear to
god i'll never do one of these [__]
things again i'm covered i'm up to date
with everybody i can't [__] believe
it
you know
part of the reason i didn't want to go
back to colorado at that time was
because i did it on child support but
once the child support was paid
and i didn't know a lot i owe like three
months i was buying like 900 bucks but
for me 900 bucks in those days was a lot
of [__] money
so finally like in august i think it was
august or maybe
it was like august and i got a job in
englewood cliffs selling cars up there
at a mazda dealer it was like a mazda vw
store
it was a little peaceful i you know
listen man
just having peace of mind at that time
for a month
that month of august was just peace of
mind like i had nothing to worry about
money i kept my jobs i kept doing
[__] stand up
i kept snorting coke you know
and uh
somewhere in the month of august i go
you know what
my time in new jersey is done
i uh
i bit a little bit more off than i chew
you know what i'm saying i wasn't in any
trouble nobody was looking for me i
don't know if those creepy dudes that i
tied up were looking for me all over
harlem
but uh
i was done i was like i want to go back
i figured out what i want to do with
comedy and i figured out
what i didn't want to do with my life i
had all this clarity now you know
but believe it to joey my friends call
me again
and they're like uh we're gonna do
something this week we got a line on a
guy you know
so one of the other guys i don't know
what was going on in his life so it was
just down to me and my buddy and
we followed a guy for a few days for a
few nights we would follow him like from
i don't know
my buddy had to rent the car
and he had you had to rent the car in
those days but he had to rent the car it
looked like a cop car
so he had rented the car
now in 91 oh my god in 91 i came to
jersey for a week i was still married
and i rented a car and they gave me one
of those police cars and i still
remember vividly going to harlem and
going hey i need some coke and they're
like no
i remember going to yankee stadium to
bike
driving my brother get crack and he goes
you'll definitely sell your coke up
there i'll definitely get it for you
they sold him the crack they would not
sell me the [__] coke and this
goddamn white whatever i don't even know
it's a big [__] car
so we had to rent the car he had a
rental car i didn't have no credit cards
that time i don't even think i had a
[__] license
he rented a car and [__] uh we
followed this guy for about two nights
until about four in the morning
and then uh the third night we follow
him in the daytime he goes we gotta do
some in the daytime with this guy
because i want to see where he makes his
deliveries to
this was supposedly a stash house that
held the coke and then they would make
different deliveries to spots in the
city and the bronx and queens whatever
so we followed the guy he didn't have a
nice car it was like a beat up honda
civic or something i think it was a
honda civic the hatchback i don't know
if you guys remember that old [__]
car
and uh
we followed him out of 178th street
and he took the west side highway to go
south like to go to like times square
42nd street whatever i don't know if
he's going times square i'm just saying
he they went south
so he jumped on him
we jumped on him as he made it was
[__] like god interfered he he got on
we had followed him but my man knew how
to get on that
uh spot of the bridge we didn't go on
the bridge we got off the bridge we went
on the 78th street which is right behind
port authority right there we waited
maybe
i don't know a half hour and then the
guy took off we're like we're we're live
so we follow him and at one point we
kind of lost him but then we met up with
him again like very i wasn't chasing him
i was just sitting in the passenger side
and this [__] looked and he saw
me and he [__] stepped on it i don't
know what i don't know if i looked like
a mobster character in 1993 this is
before the sopranos i don't know what
the [__] happened this guy's shot he
shot so hard he went on the
[__] shoulder of the west side
highway and then pulled over
he screeched his tires
stopped the car and ran out of the
[__] car you guys you can't write
this
you cannot write this [__] story he
just runs out of the car and starts
jumping over the [__] west side
highway cars are beeping at him and [__]
he's running me and my boy just pull
over
he goes to the driver's side [__] car
was wide open
he goes it's getting the [__] car
somewhere he popped the glove
compartment nothing we went and this and
the cars are driving by us on the west
side highway you do know this right cars
are [__] driving by i'm over there
waving vote for me finally [__]
finally [__] we go in the trunk and
then they uh
two nice [__] blocks
we pulled them out on broad daylight we
put him in my boy's car
he gave me like 500 cash and he goes i'm
gonna go get rid of him and give you the
balance tonight i got to pay off the
cops and pay you off
and uh
he came that night to my house and gave
me a nice chunk of money
and it was like [__] poetry in motion
i got the doe
i paid some out
i uh
i don't know what i did i bought some
clothes guys my cl i had one suit
i would wear the same suit every day i
would wash the shirt i had one white
shirt guys
you want to talk about struggle i had
one white shirt college shirt and i
would have to take it off at night
[__] spray the collar wash it by hand
dry it and then [__] iron it in the
morning i did that six days of [__]
week with the same
white shirt by the time i got a new
shirt five months later there was such a
[__] stain under here between the
coke and the petroleum and the pollution
in the air in new york city it was it
was god awful guys
god awful i remember that i took that
money and i hit it
and i started planning my [__] escape
from new jersey i saw the following
saturday i saw the car this [__] girl
that was beautiful she came in with this
nebulous [__] boyfriend i thought she
was beautiful i didn't see them
i couldn't see these guys i couldn't see
the body on her
with this kid this kid didn't know how
to [__] yeah trust me
so
you when you sell somebody a car you got
to call them to
check in with them you know like how's
the car going do you need any me to
explain anything else about the warranty
whatever
and i started calling she started
calling me and we hit it off
and one day she told me she goes i'm
thinking i'm moving to colorado i'm like
what
what are you saying and she i thought
she like [__] read my cards or
something
i told her i had lived in colorado
i never told i was thinking of going
back because i didn't know how long we
were gonna last i didn't want the girl
to go well i don't want to date this guy
she was nice i hadn't had a girlfriend
in [__] a year
she didn't do drugs she was a drug
counselor believe it or not that's a
[__] nightmare for a guy like me
and
uh everything was going great and i went
and i took some of the money i'll never
forget this
my buddy the criminal invited me to a
jet game the jets were playing the
philadelphia eagles at giant stadium at
the time 93
september october had to be september
and i'll never forget on the way down
and i'm the kiss of that
when it came to gambling for years
because i didn't know what i was doing
and uh
and i [__]
put like a thousand dollar bet
on the jets getting one or something
something weird though and randall
cunningham the star quarterback of the
[__]
uh whatever got hurt and the jets ended
up winning and ended up winning another
two thousand dollars or something i'm
like you know what
i'm getting the [__] out of here i'm
taking my earnings
and it's time to [__] go
when i read that [__] story the other
day
when i was going through on the phone
with erica and [__] uh to book people
it
i had a [__] i don't know i had to go
smoke pot
i think i even went ahead of sangria
with my wife i was like what the [__]
was that chapter about i just started
thinking about and going how the [__]
did i ever [__] survive this [__]
life i have no idea guys how the [__]
did i go from there
to going to the comedy store into going
on sets with people that are nice people
nice human being do you understand how
much insecurity i had for years
like when when people would invite me to
their homes and [__] i'm like don't
these people know i'm gonna rob them
like i i couldn't understand why people
like me for years because when somebody
did like me i i could never understand
when somebody
opened their trust to me i really
couldn't understand
i'm like the [__] i did if these people
would know it i still remember walking
on the first set
i ever walked on was basketball
and i still remember [__] going
they're gonna do a background check
okay it's just stupid like how does
universal sony these are multi-million
dollar corporations how are they not
doing a background check on me
before i come on this [__] set
they just took it for granted some lady
called her and said she had a guy
that she could read for that audition
and you just trust him and he comes in
one day and you just put them on a set
with millions of dollars in equipment
and [__] i'm like they're gonna do a
background check on me
i worked no [__] prom
and i got other jobs i've been being on
mad tv for the first time i'm going
fox is definitely doing a background
[__] check on me
nope
it's just uh
it's just [__] it was unbelievable
and i started working it took years for
me to shake that stigma
like you know how long it took me to
tell these [__] stories i kind of
remember i met rogan in 97 and on the
road we were telling stories about book
making and mugging
[__] drug dealers and they go what
are you gonna tell these stories upstage
and i go i'm never telling those on
stage i don't ever want somebody you
think i wanted to tell you guys the
story today
i never wanted to say it and trust me
if you know anything about uncle joey
there's more to the story that i'm
leaving out there's another
particle in here that i really can't
[__] say
uh
yeah you know listen when i was doing
that [__] you know
i pray every day that god forgives me
for
thief and all those years but i don't
ever felt bad from thief and from a drug
dealer i really didn't i never did it's
everybody knew what time it was
when you get into that when you sign
that paper and you become a drug dealer
you go into a different realm you become
a target for people
you know that's why i tell you before
you bring drugs into your house to
[__] sell them realize what comes
with that [__]
you know you got a little sister in the
house you got a dad in the house your
mom your grandma these people today
don't give a [__] jack you know if
somebody came to me and said to me from
to 2000
now
95 if somebody came to me and said
mike's got 20 thousand in this house
that's mine
not today
but tomorrow
that's my money
20 000 cash in this house and he's
telling people
he's too stupid i gotta rob him
i gotta rob him just because he's that
[__] stupid
i had a friend of mine who used to hide
his drugs
in his driveway under his car
people walk by you see the [__] coke
cans and i used to take one every
[__] day why because if you're that
[__] stupid i'm gonna [__] rob you
but anyway i i just wanna
i just sometimes i i think about my life
and i go what the [__]
where do these stories come from
you know
when i told her that story like me and
erica were going through this you got to
guys remember we started doing this
december
of 2020
and i was [__] up
and i still remember having surgery
laying up in the daytime with my leg and
her calling me and me being [__] up on
pain pills
slobbering and [__] you know and
telling these stories
but even then with all the [__] pain
pills and whatever else was going on i
would write the chapters out to prepare
them because i wanted to give her a good
chapter but
she caught these chapters erica did a
[__] great job on this book i when i
looked at
the few chapters i did uh last week and
then i started just reviewing them just
to see what the [__] i said you know
what the [__] did i who knows what i
[__] said those four or five months
but when i said this story and in the
book it's a little bit more detailed i
just don't want to i want you to when
you read the book you get a couple
[__] surprises i don't want them that
you're going to go well i read this
already well joey said this already i've
already said each of these stories three
[__] times but when you read them
they're gonna hit you a little
differently the same way they hit me
like i'm i'm already a little scared
that
by reading this you guys are gonna go i
can't [__] hang with joey no more
this is
this is too [__] crazy
and
the name of the book is tremendous
the story of a comedy savage
uh
and
somebody from patreon [__] i did a
little contest on patreon and somebody
gave me a couple guys gave me [__]
great ideas but somebody on patreon gave
me that idea and i gotta announce it
this week because i keep forgetting the
[__] announcement i took a picture of
all of them don't forget tomorrow night
i'm in the f oh no tonight [__]
i'm at [__] uncle vinnie's in point
please i'm looking forward to it some of
my neighbors are coming and tomorrow
night i'm in [__] uh
the stress factory and then next week i
don't know what i got i think i'm doing
uh something on the 28th
and that's it guys we're back to [__]
normal here this shit's running again
my mind i got some clarity and i'm ready
to [__] sling some dick
i love that you still support me we're
gonna start putting so we got a great
guest coming on next week hopefully
that'll all work out and after that i
got some more surprises coming it's just
taking some time guys i got a lot of my
plate right now now they threw this book
at me
you know it's it's [__] too much
lately but i love you [__]
thank you for supporting the joint thank
you for always uh
giving this love and uh i hope you
enjoyed the [__] uh
amp show last night i drew some
[__] heat on i opened up with
looks to kill by motley crew the place
went nuts i love motley crue anyway and
by the way i heard a little rumor that
motley crue is killing def leppard on
the road that they don't know how much
longer def leppard could headline on it
they're just going up there and they're
flagrant like a [__] motley cruise
[__] strong and that guitarist
everybody was writing him off
that motherfucker's throwing some
[__] heat on the road i they were in
hershey pennsylvania last week
on the 12th and i [__] up so maybe we
could catch him on the next tour then
poison
def leopard who the [__] knows i love
you [__] with all my heart
thank you for supporting the joint i'll
see you next week and now for a word
from my [__] sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you for the you're beating
we'll have some guests for you next week
but until then listen you have your
board i got something for you it's hot
outside you're sitting there you're like
the freeze pipe [__] get a little
[__] uncle joey's
reefer and get that freeze pipe going
let me tell you something about freeze
pipe it's a [__] bung it's a pipe
it's a bubbler
there's three different ones i don't
want to confuse you this ain't [__]
the james bond thing here
but it's tremendous what you do is
it comes in two pieces maybe three
pieces you take the one piece off you
put in the freezer when you're ready to
see the devil you take it out you put it
in you pack up the [__] bowl and you
burn that [__] next thing you
know you're blowing smoke that you don't
even know is in your lungs why because
the smoke has cooled down
that's what i'm talking about your smoke
is so [__] cold you'll be like a
[__] penguin shaping shaking in that
[__] corner let me explain something
to you i've used every type of hat 40
years of smoking dopey i used everything
from the apple
to the finger i used it all freeze pipe
is the [__] best because it cools
down the smoke by hundreds of degrees
and takes care of your throat your lungs
you'll feel better you understand me
it's the way if you're gonna see the
devil
you should invite the freeze pipe over
your house and it starts with you listen
[__] uncle joey's taking care of
you so go to the freezepipe.com
pressing code joey
to save 10 on your first order get
yourself a new bong a pipe or a bubble
listen you're gonna love whatever the
[__] you get that's how good the freeze
pipe is so that's the freezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10
freeze pipe like a snowball and a
[__] bung
take care of yourself guys it's hot out
there you don't want your lungs to
[__] collapse get that freeze pipe
and smoke till the smoke comes out of
your ears the joint is also brought to
you by
cbd lion listen you think cbd lines been
with me for this long because i don't
like them or they're not a good product
i like everything cbd lion puts out from
the cream to the back walls to the
kinesiology tape your shoulders are
stiff do what i do before i go to bed
you take a piece of tape you cut it and
you put it on your shoulder just a one
inch piece of tape you're gonna [__]
feel tremendous after three two days you
the shoulders won't bother you when you
sleep that's cbd lion they got something
for [__] everything cream roll on
cream
back balls gummies delta eight gummies
which will make you see the devil but it
starts with you go to cbdline.com right
now
pressing code joey your joint and get 20
off and i'm going to give you 20 off on
the delta h2 you know how expensive
those [__] are so go to
cbdlion.com right now
and get the party started i want to
thank the freeze pipe i want to thank
cbd lion i want to thank better help
manscape and blue chew for having our
back this week but i also want to thank
you [__] for being solid
stay black have a great week hopefully
i'll see one of you is tonight at uncle
vinnie's or tomorrow at the stretch
factory if not i'll see you next monday
tip top [__] magoo stay black
guys
you